as a production designer what are some
of the first few things you do when you
first sign on with a job when I first
signed onto a job I've usually read the
script and met with the director so
those were the preliminary things and
often when I if it's a director I
haven't worked with before I make a
presentation to show them at my meeting
my first meeting with them before I have
the job of my sort of visual concept for
the movie and with Todd I've worked with
Todd before so I didn't have to do that
and so I'm when I met with should I talk
about when I met with Todd specifically
you can I met with Todd specifically it
was myself and Ed Lachman the
cinematographer who I've worked with
before and Sandy Powell the costume
designer and we all met in New York
where I live and Todd kind of we had a
long discussion about the general
feeling that he was trying to go for in
Carroll and we talked a lot about the
period of 1952 in New York City and how
it wasn't really the bright sunny 1950s
that people usually think of mid-century
modern period but it was this darker
post-war period so that was one of the
most important things we talked about
and then we talked about Saul Leiter the
photographer and some other
photographers who had been photographing
New York at that time and the looks that
they had achieved in their photographs
and how we were going to emulate some of
their elements in the look of the movie
and from there there's a few things that
I do when I start a movie and they're
sort of at going on at the same time I
start location scouting and that's a
huge part of the movies I work on
because some of them have very big
builds but they always have a lot of
locations and and at the same time I'm
assembling a wall a big wall of visual
reference that sort of shows what I
think is the look of the movie and of
research there's specific research so
for a period movie there's a lot of
specific research that has to be done
what color were fire hydrants in New
York in 1952 they were black by the way
but I didn't know that so this is the
kind of thing that you know it's
all this trivia but you have to know it
to make a realistic looking movie so you
have the visual reference and the
research and the third thing that is
important for the beginning of my
process is to have is to figure out the
color palette of the movie so I myself
have a large collection of vintage paint
decks and um paint chips and I bring
that to every movie I work on nineteen
not just period once and so we looked at
the paint chips from the 40s and the 30s
and the early 50s and picked out a sort
of range of colors that we wanted to
work with and then I had my charge
scenic hats brought who came with me
from New York to Cincinnati do a lot of
color samples two by four two by two
color samples which we lined up around
the room and at the same time my set
decorator
Heather Leffler was getting fabric
samples that we matched with the color
samples so we sort of had a Torres's
apartment section on a Carol's house
section and all the different motels
section and the toy store so we're kind
of creating little pieces of all the
different worlds that you can actually
walk into the art department and and get
an idea of what the movie is going to
look like and in the sense of the color
palette are you assembling a color
palette and a mood based on a time
period most instances or a characters
mood and sort of who they are both both
so in a period movie or you know you're
starting with the time period because
you you need to have period accuracy in
order to let the viewer forget about the
fact that they're watching a period
movie but you don't want anything to
draw them out of that period in a sense
so they're watching a movie it takes
place in 1952 and there's something that
looks not quite right over there and
even if they're not consciously noticing
it subconsciously it may distract them
for a moment so I really try hard to
create a very as accurate a world as
possible so that then everyone can
forget about it and focus on the story
is it ultimately we all of us crowds
people want people to focus on this
and the characters and not you know the
costume or the sofa or the walls or the
fire hydrant but really on the
characters so so first you're starting
with what in New York look like it
looked like this
what is our particular New York gonna
look like you know which aspects of that
New York are we choosing to put in that
in our movie and finally what do our
characters worlds look like within that
context so in 1952 in the Far East Side
of Manhattan
what would to res this characters
apartment have looked like so it's it's
kind of a process of getting from going
from the big picture down to the small
picture how much do you pay attention to
tiny details I noticed in the film you
know she was an aspiring photographer so
you'd see some you know photos on her
thing but it was very sort of sparse in
other places yes I mean I pay a lot of
attention to detail it's everyone that
works with me knows that I do so I know
that there are designers who give oh you
know almost sort of don't get that
involved with set-dressing at all for
example and their set decorator does
their own thing and the designer is
doing something else but I and their pop
master but I I work with a lot of people
I've worked with before I have a very
great team of people that I've worked
with over and they all know that you
know I'm gonna get involved and I and I
do but we have a great collaboration so
I pay attention to everything everything
that I can and I'm upset if there's
something I missed it always happens no
but so any negative space that you saw
for example on a wall or any sparsit's
that was definitely planned was there a
particular location that was a little
more challenging to decide on how to
present it well the toy store was the
toy department it's the department in a
department store was a huge a huge set
for us in terms of the work that it
required and and it's also the opening
kind of not the opening side of the
movie but one of the big important set
because it's where two resumes Carol and
and you want this kind of it's the whole
world to be created in a believable
fashion
it was it took us it was a while before
we found the right location for that and
we went through a lot of different
options we scouted some we're in
Cincinnati and there were some towns
outside of Cincinnati that had closed
down department stores that were built
in the right era and this was so
exciting and we went and scouted them
and they were all wrong I mean one of
them had been to remodeled in the 1960s
and another one was too small and
another one they wouldn't put a chute
there and it wasn't that great anyway so
we were kept going through all these
different options and it was starting to
be a little scary and then we found this
great abandoned high school turn of the
Sun turn of the 20th century high school
that had this gymnasium that was
beautiful details because we we really
just needed walls floor ceiling columns
and we were going to create the rest so
this gymnasium looked good it had a
little running track and we were going
to make a mezzanine up there with toys
which I had seen in in much of the
period research and the building had no
heat or water at the moment or no
electricity and we started to they
started to make a deal with the owner
and then it it fell through it became
too expensive if he started asking for
more money I don't even know what
happened but suddenly we had no location
and we really had nothing and then my
decorator Heather Leffler said I've been
shopping at this fabric store meal end
and they have a it's a multi floor
building and I think maybe one of the
floors would be good for the toy
department so we went and looked it was
a big storage floor and it was filled
with junk I mean just covered but we
knew it was the right place right away
and immediately we brought Todd and he
loved it and we surveyed it and started
clearing it out and so that was that was
the beginning of victoy department now
you began doing production design in
1992 is that when your first job was or
that might have been the first movie I
designed but right but then there was a
long gap in between that and my next one
because I it was when I started working
in the film business which I think was
1989 it was very easy to in a way to get
jobs as a production designer I just
fell into that job
it wasn't I didn't know if I wanted to
do it and right after that sublet I
decorated a movie and I kind of was
didn't know what I was doing then I
became a set dresser so it was it kind
of for me not very well directed period
and then I took a break and did
something else for four years
and I came back to the film business and
I knew I wanted to be a production
designer it just was this revelation in
me and like I can't explain I had no
basis in anything and it at that point
had become a very popular this was 1997
had become a very popular job and a lot
of people wanted to do it and people I
had known when they were interns were
suddenly production designers so I
thought it would be easy but it took
three years of working really really
hard and just like constantly going for
jobs and being rejected and and a lot of
rejection before I I finally got a
couple of movies in a row and I made the
decision like now I'm a production
designer it was the year 2000 and I'm
not going to do anything else and that
was when my career really started sound
like you needed those four years to find
out maybe what you didn't want and then
yes exactly it was great I don't regret
it because it really showed me what I
wanted and sometimes you know you never
know what's going to show you that in
life
sure well starting out for someone today
since it's much more competitive yes
would you recommend would you recommend
of course interning and then how would
someone prove that they were worthy of
promoting yes I would recommend
interning and I'd recommend working as a
PA and I'd recommend theirs well I think
that one thing I've noticed is that
there's so many things but I'm trying to
think what to say first you have to know
that it's the right thing for you so in
that sense I mean you have to be willing
to work very long hours you have to be
willing to it's a tough business and
there's a lot of hierarchy and there's a
lot of personalities and you have to be
able to cope with that you can't be too
sensitive you know and it's hard that's
a learning curve you have to be patient
I think you should always be working
below your skill level I think that
working you know at a level that which
you're not really
qualified for is just gonna be a bit
mistake in your career and I made that
mistake I took a job as a prop master I
didn't know what I was doing I got fired
you know and it taught me a lesson so I
think you should always be aware that
should always be kind of more prepared
for then you then you should be for the
job I think a lot of people just out of
college are impatient I don't blame them
they want to get started they want to be
this or that but I think there's so much
to learn and you should make your
mistakes when no one's gonna see them
and you know I designed student movies I
designed a student movie they took place
in 1968 and I filled it with every piece
of kitsch from 1968 that I could think
of you know if I would never do that
now as a designer and I did that on a
student movie that nobody ever saw and
I'm glad I got that out of my system so
you're gonna make mistakes make them
when nobody's watching
don't make them when someone's watching
and I might not hire you the next time
so I think patience hardwork ambition
not taking it you know not being too
sensitive those are just character
traits and they're really important for
this business and then on top of that
you know watch a lot of movies and look
at a lot of art and look a lot of
photography and know what you're talking
about because it's not just about design
it's about cinema I mean to me it's
about cinema and it's about designing a
movie it's not about designing a set so
the directors I meet with they want to
talk about other movies you know they
don't want to talk about building a set
and I think that that's the most
important thing for any of us working at
a creative level in this business is
we're working on movies and whatever
kinds of movies we want to work on you
know everybody's got their things some
people want to do superhero movies and
some people want to do low-budget period
movies and some people want to do
romantic comedies everybody or fantasy
movies it's you know everybody's got
their thing that they want to do but
know that know that genre that you're
working in or know that that group of
films because all films inform the next
film that comes along and and you have
to love it so it's you know everything
that I do in my life is really related
to my work and I can't really separate
it when I go on vacation on
photographs of signs that I might use as
research in a movie and I enjoy it it's
not like I turn it off because I'm done
with my job it's ongoing and it's worth
it but you have to love it I wanted to
go back to the student film that you
referenced just a little bit ago and you
said you filled it with everything from
that time here why was that bad was that
overkill it was overkill because at no
point in history ever unless maybe in a
hotel room like we are right now is
everything from the same time period in
a domestic interior there's layers of
things so you have furniture that was
inherited from somebody's parents or you
have something they bought ten years ago
you have a new copy of a magazine you
have some old glasses that were bought
at a flea market I'm just giving
examples but if you think about you know
almost any interior that's been lived in
for more than six months represents many
time periods and in this case that film
was about a family's house and that
family had had that house for a while so
it would have been crazy for everything
to have been from the year in which the
movie took place just wouldn't be
realistic and there are for sure period
movies serious period movies that are
designed that way and it's just um it
can be fun for viewers you know because
it's like oh look at that fridge and
look at that this and but I don't think
it's a very accurate representation of
the period and I think it's a little
distracting when you talk about layers I
like that let's suppose someone is in a
situation and their life is more in
turmoil but then you see that their home
is so well put together like me at all
well yeah but that sort of embodied who
she was yeah I got that but but there's
been other movies do you ever fight to
maybe mess it up a little
someone's sort of that put a little more
chaos in the way they're living because
it just seemed a little too perfect for
who the character is or well yeah I mean
I don't tend to like I mean I think that
that was a very appropriate setting for
Carol because she also has help yes you
know he's not cleaning it up herself so
that house is not going to be too messy
but she's very wealthy but yes I think
that I don't tend to like things to be
too pretty because they don't tend to
look that way in real life whether
they're pure
at her contemporaries so I like a bit of
chaos and I like a bit of messiness and
I like a dangling electrical cord you
know especially something that takes
place in here I designed the pilot for
girls and I was very based that a lot on
my own experience of living in bad
apartments in New York and and I made
sure to put a lot of those elements in
many of which are gone now um but so
that kind of thing is important to me I
think it shows it makes the place seem
real as opposed to artificial and an
artificial movie set versus reality